all right we're going to go ahead and
start the video yeah what should i do
you do an intro you can say your tag
line that you like i don't want to do
that anymore
don't do it you know i had a thought the
other day that i just didn't why do i
keep doing that
it's because the system has put this
pressure on me
to feel like it's not a real video on my
channel unless it's got that stupid tag
line in the front but i kind of
like it i hate it
oh no hi welcome oh now i do feel like i
can't start unless i say how many years
grace holly didn't know now you know
your life is different now
i know this is and this is how
millennials put everything up
time for another hello fresh video they
somehow
really support me in these trying times
and i
accept all the support and love from
them i love them so much that i actually
cut off the tip of my thumb
making one of their meals not for a
video just for life
scallions got me it was chop chop chop
it the one the chops felt thick
today we're making now i feel nervous
that you're here do you know
i'm gonna i'm gonna make a decision and
that is to
for you to leave but then to try this at
the end with me
that's perfect okay i'm very excited
today we're making
beef and cheese tostadas what did
what did what did uh what did the what
did the beef
say to the very voluptuous cheese
when they got together for the first
time those tatas
there's a joke there work it in
something smells like burning and we
haven't done anything yet elliot turned
the oven on before we started anyway
it's a beautiful day outside so let's
stay inside
let's get our kitchen hot bothered and
man i am sleepy let me pump myself up
for a second
let's get into some talking points do
you know what hellofresh is if you don't
you
are extremely dumb hello fresh is
america's
number one meal kit it's a subscription
meal service
that brings fresh meals to you
what is burning it's a potato from last
night okay
now it's great the whole kitchen smells
like burning don't mind me
i'm just gonna be suppressing a fake
stroke this entire
video america's number one meal kit that
delivers pre-measured ingredients
and delicious recipes right to your door
so you can get a meal on the table
in about 30 minutes or a lot more than
30 minutes
if you're me hellofresh has more
five-star recipes than any other meal
kit so you know you're gonna get
something good and if it's not good
it'll be different and different isn't
bad unless you
cook it wrong because you are incapable
hellofresh is also super flexible you
can change up your delivery days you can
change your meal preferences whenever
you want hellofresh is the opposite
of the pandemic they make it about you
that's all of our talking points for now
so let's just make this freaking meal
preheat the oven to 450 degrees
we did oh let me get the food duh
not a single egg and on
wonderful another camera angle there can
you even believe it
party first we are going to wash and dry
all the produce
let's imagine we have we did a diced
tomato roughly chopped cilantro half and
peel the onion
this is the knife that i cut off the tip
of my thumb with you have to face your
fears to move through them so it's you
and me and if you do that again
ooh it's definitely my fault and not
yours wash your hands wash your produce
wear a mask all right let's dice this
tomato
anyone else just kind of like slowly
realizing the different
subtle and sometimes not so subtle ways
that they're unraveling
pretty cool not only are we trapped in
the prisons of our own homes
because a lot of people aren't following
the rules but we're also trapped in the
prison of our own brains
roughly chop the cilantro here's a fun
first date idea
and don't mind me i'm being actually
sincere with your day ordered a
hellofresh meal each of you cooked it
over zoom with each other while you're
chatting how freaking cute would that be
ugh it needs someone to throw up very
cute
half and peel the onion thinly slice one
half those people that
refuse to wear masks they're like onions
you guys they have a lot of layers
and you gotta work to peel them away and
when you peel them away you realize
every single layer is the same stupid
stanky selfish
layer of an onion finely chop this until
we have
two tablespoons now we quarter our lime
okay now we take these this little
grinch heart and we slice it into strips
take it off strip we're officially done
step one onto step two
in a small bowl we're gonna make our
salsa and our crema
combine the tomato cilantro and chopped
onions then we want the juice from half
a lime
ooh and then a pinch of salt and pepper
and that's our salsa mix it up
salsa is so easy to make now we put that
to the side now we're going to take
another small bowl what sour cream
this little packet of sour cream is
going to do an impression of
an entitled middle age upper middle
class white woman from orange county and
i'm going to play
the rest of society um you got to wear a
mask if you're in here
no i deserve anything i want
wonderful now i put as much as the hot
sauce as we want we got some cholula
sauce that's good and then we stir in
some water so it reaches a drizzling
consistency
says to make it a drizzling consistency
but i like mine yeah step three we are
going to brown
our beef we're gonna add our beef our
southwest spice and our chili powder
and a few big pinches of salt and then
we're gonna cook it till it's cooked for
four to five minutes i'm sorry if you're
a vegetarian
we gotta cook it and break it up this
meat is not staying together i don't
care how much it's got in common i don't
care how good
it makes itself as a person it's it's
time to break up i don't care if you
have the same taste in movies
ooh has anyone broken up with anyone
during the pandemic
please leave a detailed comment below
citing exactly how it went down
thank you okay while the meat cooks i'm
going to attempt a tick-tock dance
okay once the beef is browned we're
gonna add the green pepper and the
sliced onion and a pinch of salt and
cook it now we're gonna cook that for
like another five to seven minutes what
else is going on with
you guys the cool thing i will say is
that i have been able to find a lot of
little like nooks and crannies in my
house that i didn't know
were there before to cry quietly to
myself moving on to step five we're
gonna bake our tortillas we drizzled
olive oil over them
and coated them all as prick them with a
fork
all right this is cathartic we bake them
for four to five minutes per side
we'll see if i do that well that bakes
now we're going back to our peppers
onions and beef and we're gonna add our
stock concentrate and a fourth cup of
water and we're gonna cook it for one to
two minutes
all right what are we where what what
are we
doing our beef is basically done our
tortillas are cooking i'm
to put it all together and then i'm
going to show you what they look like
[Music]
worth it
just let this little fat dollops flop
wherever they want that's called art
[Music]
it's time wait it's not time it's
you gotta make a thing that says like
this is what they look like and then
this is what they
this is how she looks when she tries her
best to look really beautiful but this
is how she looks
because she's nice all looking all the
time that was the original lyrics
that one direction song welcome to the
uh
beef and cheese tostadas here's a joke
for you what what did the beef
say to the voluptuous cheese when it met
it for this
before they made this meal what those
tatas
i'd love that i'll eat it with you i
know they're toast tata so they're
basically it's a crunchy shell makes the
plate and you're just
good luck cheers cheers it's gonna take
a lot of bites before we get to them not
if you stop
talking this is a no-brainer
this is hard to mess up um
i'm going to work it right it's very
good you guys know that with every
hellofresh video that i make
you guys get to take away something if
you're interested in hellofresh
guess what yeah guys get started now
with 80
of your first month of hellofresh good
hellofresh.com and enter
hellbig 80. again use code helbig80 to
get 80
off with purchase including free
shipping on your first box go to
hellofresh.com for more details anything
else you'd like to let them know
no this is wonderful baby thank you guys
so much for watching i hope you enjoyed
this and thank you hello fresh for
sponsoring this video as always see you
guys next time
i don't know hopefully tick tock dance
see anyone can do it anywhere that's the
biggest danger
of 2020 is that anyone can just start
going
yep look out that's spreading